[Music]
for them to run out and claim that it's
republicans who want to defund the
police
that's like an arsonist showing up at
the fire and blaming the firemen that's
like the chinese
blaming the americans for the wuhan
virus
that's like oj saying he's going to help
find
the real killer that's like democrats
saying
they're the ones that want to build the
wall it's absurd
it's ridiculous and they know it but you
know what they're also counting on the
media
all encircling joe biden and saying
poor uncle joe he doesn't want to
abolish your police
well last time i checked bill de blasio
the democratic mayor of new york
campaigned on defunding the police cut a
billion dollars from the nypd and you
know what de blasio was standing on that
same
democratic stage with joe biden yeah the
democrats are facing a lot of backlash
as they're trying to blame the
republicans
to push to defund the police well
sean hannity joins us right now he's up
early he's got a big day coming
it's a miracle i'm up early how did that
ever happen did you not go to bed
uh about three three thirty somewhere in
there brian
about when you get up for work right now
that's a little late for us we're up
earlier than that
and what a lot of people because you're
going to the southern border right
you can keep your hours i promise uh i
think
the the toughest in tv by the way ted
cruz was funny last night
last night so so we watched last summer
and it was horrible right
we're watching uh city blocks being
taken over
summer of love zone chaz chop autonomous
zone
uh police precincts being burned to the
ground
we watched the looting the writing we
watch three thousand cops
injured pelted with rocks bricks
water frozen water bottles and and
by the way all of those people
apparently are not going to be
charged in what they did and now
the democrats who are almost completely
and utterly silent and refuse to call
them riots
now they've decided to say it's the
republicans fault
um george orwell was a little ahead of
his time because that's about as
1984-ish
as uh i can think of the the democrats
had to come up with a new
uh strategy and a new narrative because
crime is through the roof
and so last week out of nowhere joe
biden said
he made an announcement you know and by
the way police can use
the money from the covid bill and that's
new and so then
jinsaki earlier this week was talking
about that's right
it's actually the republicans who
defunded the police because they would
not vote
for the 1.9 trillion dollar
bill which does not anywhere in the bill
mention police kamala harris praised
the defunding efforts that took place in
california in los angeles specifically
kamala harris also promoted the bail
fund in
minneapolis it was new york city
that cut a billion dollars from the
police budget crime went through the
roof
uh then they come up with these insane
no bail laws which is that
if they catch you brian you better be
careful you're a bank robber in your
spare time
if if you rob a bank if you write
no literally there was one bank robber
that was on the front cover of one of
the
tabloids in new york rob's a bank
there's no bail they let him out he goes
out and robs another bank
they let him out he robs another bank
and he's like thanking governor cuomo
and
and comrade de blasio uh for allowing
him to continue this very important
craft of his
and profession which is robbing banks
because they wouldn't put them in jail
uh but that's the same thing that they
were doing to those people that were
rioting and looting and involved in
arson look if you look at where this is
happening
last year we had record increases in
violent crime
in in every case these are blue states
blue cities run by democrats for decades
they're the ones that push the defunding
of the police it's twisted logic on
their part
one of the reasons i think they're doing
it is because polling now shows
overwhelmingly that the country is
rightly blaming the democrats for
policies
that are not keeping law and order
simple concept
if we want to be able to pursue
happiness right we're endowed by our
we can tell joe biden create or god the
creator of everything we're down by our
creator
uh life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
if you don't have law and order and
safety and security
you cannot pursue happiness and sadly
that is the case
for way too many people in way too many
cities
it's a problem we do know how to solve
if we set our mind to solving it
you know the folks don't like defunding
and they don't like what's happening
down on the border
president trump is heading there kamala
went last week
and then we just learned this morning
well she she kind of went there last
week
she went there for a photo op last week
but not where all the
where she should have been the children
her trip to
but sean we learned this morning there
was a two-year-old child that was found
on the mexico side abandoned on the side
of the road
we keep seeing these stories we keep
seeing these images here's the picture
of it
wow but but you know ainsley
we've seen this before that you know how
many times have
all right the walls that are built and
you see people
literally pulling these children up to
the top of the wall
and dumping them over dropping them over
how is it possible matt you know it
always comes down to
imagine if donald trump were president i
agree with steve that the only reason
that kamala harris made an attempt at
this photo op which is what it turned
out to be
is because donald trump announced that
he was going to the border we will be
there with him we'll be there with greg
abbott today
is because he went there imagine if
donald trump is president
in the middle of a pandemic and the
images that we
saw of real i call them they're cages
they're plastic cages but the kids were
trapped inside them
they had no opportunity to leave them
they're overcrowded in the middle of a
pandemic
living on top of each other high rate of
of testing positive for covid military
bases
military bases and sexual assaults
right exactly and then they wouldn't
allow the
governor of texas to send in child
protective services to even look at
these children
now yeah you know what if we don't
protect these kids
we're doing everybody a disservice here
it's a 25-year high
we're probably on record now to bring in
millions of illegal immigrants in the
dark of night they're
literally transporting them to all the
different states in in the country
and then the states are then burdened
because they're not allowed to
circumvent federal law
it gets a little complicated and the
states that are responsible for food
water
shelter uh for health care and education
and and they can we can barely afford it
for american citizens right now
so what's going to be your approach uh
tonight you got the governor of texas
and you have the former president united
states uh
are you going to be seeing what they're
doing tonight bringing that to the show
how do you plan on progressing through
this town hall you know brian
if if you would have told me that joe
biden's
economy would be this bad this quickly i
don't think i would have believed it it
usually takes a little bit longer
if you would have told me they would
open the borders
it's beyond open borders because you
don't get to pick and choose in america
none of us are allowed to pick and
choose what laws we choose to obey and
what laws we choose not to obey
and not only is joe biden and kamala
harris they're
they're they're choosing not to enforce
the laws of the land
respecting our law our borders our
sovereignty
then they're aiding and abetting in the
law breaking because they're only
processing people that are coming in
they abolish the state of mexico program
highly successful they abolished
building the wall
they not only brought back catch and
release but it's basically
catch and we'll process you and have a
good life in america
uh program of joe and kamala but
then they're providing all of the
services on the backs of the american
taxpayer
i'm all for immigration legal
immigration
so right so that's going to be the focus
tonight that'll be a big part of it yeah
the other thing is is 90 of the heroine
in this country
comes across that border we have an
opioid crisis
95 of the fentanyl in this country that
is killing many
children on average 300 americans a week
are dying
that is crossing that southern border
i've been down to the southern border in
the course of my career
this might be my 15th time i've been by
the way if you want to see really funny
film watch me on horseback
i've been on horseback all-terrain
vehicles
shoppers helicopters planes
i've seen drug warehouses i've been from
the rio grande
all the way through san diego i've seen
literally
tunnels built from mexico up into office
buildings in san diego
the problem is severe but trump had
fixed it
this problem was resolved now we're
about to hit a 25
30 year high of illegal immigrants in
the country and
and we're not even we're not we're not
even deporting illegal criminal
immigrants
in this country and i was looking up
we'll be watching tonight yeah we will
be watching i was looking up we were
talking about oakland and
it's one of the one of the most
dangerous cities in our country and i
was looking up
most dangerous cities this morning and
then it gave me cities in other
countries
there were three i think on the top ten
list and they were all along the border
of mexico
those are the folks who live there who
want to come into our country and
the bidet administration is letting them
just come in free willy-nilly
they can walk right over you know
there's a there's a human compassionate
side to this
debate but it's got to be done legally
look
i remember once i was standing in san
diego right on the border
and on the san diego side you've got
you know 500 000 homes million-dollar
homes
and then on the other side you you see
nothing but utter poverty it's not
america's role however to bring
every single person that can't take care
of themselves look
there are three criteria i would have
for entry into america number one
i would make it that way you have to
have a background check so we know
that you don't have radical associations
post covert i would say anybody that
wants to enter the country legally
they would need a health check of some
kind and the third thing i think people
would need to be able to prove is that
they're
able and capable right financially to
take care of themselves
then go through the process legally and
i don't care where you come from then my
answer is welcome to america we're glad
you're here
indeed um one more topic before you're
gonna have to go and that is
uh our president has adopted
a new way of communicating he did it
yesterday again the way he did it last
week and essentially it's george
bush it's it's read my lips i'm
whispering
hi joe biden yeah watch
we're waiting for relief i got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
i wrote the bill on the environment
why would i not be for it pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now hey guys
i think it's time to give ordinary
people a tax break
so sean hannity on on whispering
wednesday
can you explain why he's talking like
that
yes i i actually can but some people get
angry that i do it
you know i have been saying for quite a
while
we've been showing tape on hannity joe
biden in 2012 joe biden in 2016 joe
biden today
how do i say this nicely i call him very
affectionately president
sippy cup because if you look at joe's
schedule
he has less than one item usually a day
on his agenda
they hide him as often as possible did
you ever imagine we'd have a president
of the united states that's constantly
saying i i can't answer questions
because they're going to get mad at me
from the back they're going to they're
going to yell at me um he goes to bed at
like seven o'clock at night he gets his
warm milky a
sippy cup maybe a night night story and
part of it is funny but now to me it's
getting a little scary because
it's emboldening people that really
don't like us like oh
vladimir putin president xi of china kim
jong-un
iranian muellers radical islamic
terrorists
uh i am very very concerned he
he looks weak frail he's a cognitive
mess
and a steve i i don't know
what that little whisper thing is all
about but it's very odd
bizarre and strange to me right well
that's the only way i can
explain it every time every time he does
it
he makes our highlight really all right
popular item everyone wants me to give
them
i had sippy cups made up with the
presidential seal on it
everybody wants them it's going to be a
big hit
it's going to be a big hit i'll bring
one of president trump down at the
border tonight
right it'll be as big a hit as the
gutfeld t-shirt which is capturing
america's imagination
well president trump's policies worked
the policies now are not working by the
way and look how hard it is on governor
governor abbott legally he's not allowed
to
enforce federal immigration law so now
we
now he's got to spend 250 million
dollars as a start
to continue building the wall donald
trump was building so let me just tell
you how powerful you are
you're the first guest we've had in the
history of the show that no one in our
ear is saying rap
because we just really care about me i
don't rap on my own show why should i
rap on your show
i'm not even telling us to wrap you up
all right sean kennedy got a break it's
okay can you stay for another hour
calm down calm down what's that can you
stay for another hour
i'm sure i could i'll be a little late
for the interview but
we'll be watching you tonight all right
all right guys thank you
thanks for having me love your show
watch every morning thanks sean